welcome back to the David Pacman show
and thank you for joining me I Am David
packman if he was turned into a pumpkin
at midnight and then somehow for some
unexplained spiritual and magical reason
didn't quite get turned back into
himself
I'm Jesse dollar I am the host of the
dollar more daily on YouTube and I doubt
it podcast wherever podcasts are found
it can also be found on the internet
on Twitter Instagram and Tech talk now
that all the Shameless self-promotion is
out of the way let's talk about a
Shameless stealth promoter himself
George Santos this entire Saga of his
committee assignments and the sub the
the previous lies that he's told uh have
kind of culminated and he just resigned
his committee assignments that were
granted to him by Kevin McCarthy and I'm
not going to take it I don't think you
should take it on face value his his
resignation from the Committees not
standing up and being there for his
constituency which has kind of been the
the Timber and the tenor of his of his
attitude up to this point I'm going to
read a statement but then before I do I
want to talk about exactly what is what
is taking place among the Republican
caucus it's become a revenge for hire
outfit the Republican party in the house
and they're going to exact Revenge upon
democrats for removing Marjorie Taylor
Green from her committees
and they're going to do it by way of
removing ilhan Omar not allowing ilhan
Omar to be on the Foreign Affairs
committee
for a number of different reasons almost
all of them rooted in racism rooted in
fear and bigotry and xenophobia
we're going to get to all of that I got
some clips but first I'm going to read
this the statement from George Santos
and we can we can talk about this and
and kind of break it down that this it
doesn't seem genuine to me this seems
like an excuse that he was forced off of
his committees by Kevin McCarthy because
maybe maybe Kevin McCarthy knows
something that the rest of us don't know
something that's coming down the pike or
just that this was too creating too much
complication for the Republicans in
their quest to punish ilhan Omar here's
this George Santos Republican of New
York's Third District issued the
following statement requesting that he
be recused from both the house committee
on small business and the house
committee on science space and
Technology quote with the ongoing
attention surrounding both my personal
and campaign Financial investigations I
have submitted a request to speaker
McCarthy that I be temporarily recused
for my committee assignments until I am
cleared quote unquote said Congressman
Santos this was a decision that I take
very seriously the business of the 118th
Congress must continue without media
fanfare
it is important that I primarily focus
on serving the constituents of New
York's third congressional district and
providing Federal level representation
without distraction too late bro
too late
it goes on I want to personally thank
speaker McCarthy for meeting with me to
discuss the matter and allowing me to
take time to properly clear my name
before returning to my committees to my
constituents I remain committed to
serving the district and delivering
results for both New York's third
congressional district and for the
American people
I don't think any of that is true I
think that he is being forced off of his
committees by Kevin McCarthy
um for a number of different reasons
well at least two I think this is my
estimation of it when I worked for for
the Congress back in the day I worked
for the United States Senate I didn't
really have much to do on the house side
but politics is politics and I think
what's taking place here is Kevin
McCarthy either knows something's coming
down the line that's going to force his
hand or he knows that this is
complicating their racist xenophobia
um mission to remove ilhan Omar
congresswoman ilhan Omar from her post
on the Foreign Relations the Foreign
Affairs committee now this was asked of
of Steve scalise a leader in the House
of Representatives a leader in the
Republican Party even though years ago a
while campaigning Steve scalise said
that he's just like David Duke except
without all the baggage Steve scalise
just like the former Grand wizard of the
KKK without all that baggage
I always like to remind people what he
said he is talking here about
congresswoman ilhan Omar and he put He
juxtaposes it against what Democrats did
to Marjorie Taylor green by removing her
from her committees for things that she
said before she was even a
congressperson watch this
committee
yeah obviously we've we've been talking
to our members and and pointing out a
lot of issues because you know if you
look at what we were very concerned
about last congress with Democrats
removing Marjorie Taylor green and Paul
goes are from all of their committees
this is not the same in a number of
regards number one they went after
Marjorie Taylor green for things that
she had said before she was a member of
Congress that she denounced before she
was a member of Congress it was very
personal and they removed her from every
committee even if Omar were to be
removed from the Foreign Affairs
committee she'd still be allowed to
serve on other committees so a lot of
dis big differences and if if Omar is
concerned about being removed uh
probably be good if you would ask her
why she voted to remove Marjorie Taylor
green and Go sir from their committees
because she did vote to do that
it's because of vile racism and
terroristic
um
goings-on relative to Marjorie Taylor
green not not full-on terrorism but
stalking hounding school shooting victim
survivors
uh going to the Capitol I'm going to
play a clip a little later of her going
to the Capitol to find ilhan Omar to get
her to answer why she didn't swear her
put her hand on the Bible the Holy Bible
not the Quran when she became a member
of Congress
it is a completely different thing this
is hypocrisy run amok again this is a
Revenge fantasy being fulfilled by the
Republican Party
now some of my suspicions I believe will
become your suspicions as well when you
watch Marjorie Taylor green being
interviewed what looks like in the in
the Crypt in the in the in the Labyrinth
beneath the capital by reporters and she
kind of spills the beans that
Santos needed to go because of uh their
quest to remove ilhan Omar watch this
that there was so much drama really over
the situation and
um especially what what we're doing to
work to remove ilhan Omar from the
Foreign Affairs committee Mr Santos
statement in there was just saying that
he he spoke with speaker McCarthy and
and made this decision on his own
they're doing a lot of work to try to
convince you that George Santos made
this decision on his own all while
crying crocodile tears about the prior
the previous removal of Marjorie Taylor
green for things that she said before
she was a congresswoman oh my God it was
so personal it was
and here's the clip I talked about
earlier her skulking through the halls
of the office buildings on Capitol Hill
seeking out people to answer for their
crime of breaking the law not it's not a
law that someone must put their hand on
the Bible when they swear into Congress
this woman so stupid so ignorant of our
faith Traditions or requirements lack of
requirements for Faith Traditions to be
a member of Congress that she thinks you
must swear on a Bible
to become a member of Congress watch
this
they signed that they swore in on the
Korean oh we have the Bible we're going
to talk about swearing in on the how to
swear in on the Bible with them and let
them know what our law says that you
can't swear in on the Koran so we're
gonna we're gonna explain to that you
know we're going to explain about how
you can't swear in on the Koran and
we're going to have the Bible and ask
them if they would swear in on the Bible
that we really need them yeah we have
the oath yep
but when they swore in it wasn't a law
yet right so at the time they saw it I
don't know I think at the time they
weren't that wasn't passed because it
wouldn't have been passed in a
republican control yeah so it was passed
after they swore in so they're not
really official I don't think
so let's go ask them to swear in in the
Bible because like you said well um
uh yeah it has to be the Bible Well
is not compatible with America yep
that's the bottom line
how can you say you represent women but
you support Sharia law
this is this is stunning Krueger in in
rare rare form
so certain of herself that it was
against the law at some point
to use anything other than the Holy
Bible to swear on members of Congress
were swearing on Spider-Man comic books
or Superman comic books this Congress
you can swear on anything
if I were a member of Congress I think
I'd probably put my hand upon the
Constitution of the United States since
you're also swearing an oath to support
and defend that document
she's a member of Congress and when they
act like all this was so long ago this
was before she was a congress person
this is like two years before she became
a congressperson she's a 44 year old
woman she's a middle-aged woman
skulking through the Halls to teach her
a lesson
and the unfortunate thing is they're
going to get their way relative to ilhan
Omar
who's just a just a woman trying to do
her job trying to represent her
constituency
by by all accounts a loving and decent
person who has a heart for Humanity but
not a Republican and she is now in the
crosshairs figuratively speaking for now
and they're going to exact their Revenge
not great
the other thing that is happening that
broke is that Donald Trump a deposition
a video of his deposition where he
pleaded the Fifth Amendment
over
400 times was released
and it is something that was reported on
that he pled the fifth a whole bunch of
times but when you see it and you see a
an ex-president of the United States of
America someone who again this is a turn
of phrase I use all the time Who Rose
his right hand and and swore a solemn
Oath a vow supposed to be a man of Honor
to to support and defend the
Constitution against all enemies foreign
and domestic and to to Faithfully
execute the duties the president of the
United States He gave His word he would
do that
this this person who also on the
campaign Trail and over the years has
maligned people who chose to assert
their Fifth Amendment right under the
Constitution of the United States
to against self-incrimination
here's that first let's give you a
reminder of Donald Trump's very very
settled attitude about people who plead
the Fifth
when you have your staff taking the
Fifth Amendment taking the fifth so
they're not prosecuted when you have the
man that set up the illegal server take
in the fifth
I think it's disgraceful Fifth Amendment
Bob
horrible
horrible he pleaded the fifth and that
was the end we never heard about him
again this is like Watergate
only it's worse because here our foreign
enemies were in a position to hack our
most sensitive National Security secrets
there is nothing sacred for Donald Trump
nothing
because that same man in August of this
past year sat with a deposition with
lawyers asking him questions just days
after his home Mar-A-Lago was raided by
the FBI in the Department of Justice for
the documents that endangered our
national security
and when asked questions he wrote he
read a statement
and then they asked him a question he
read another statement and asserted his
Fifth Amendment right under the
Constitution so apparently it's like the
mob it's if you're innocent why are you
pleading the fifth just using his words
against him except he did it over 400
times now obviously I'm not going to
play a clip here of him doing it 400
times but I'm gonna give you the flavor
of how this deposition went down where
he just kept referring to the statement
over and over and over watch this
uh Mr Trump I understand you have a
statement that you want to read into the
record yes
um would you please feel free to start
thank you very much
this is the greatest Witch Hunt
in the history of our country
there has never been another president
or perhaps even another politician
who has been persecuted harassed and in
every other way unfairly treated like
President Donald J Trump
what Leticia James has tried to do
the last
number of years is a disgrace to the
legal system
an affront to the New York State
taxpayers and a violation of the solemn
rights and protections afforded by the
United States
Constitution
she developed
I once asked
if you're innocent
why are you taking the Fifth Amendment I
was
asking that question
now I know the answer to that question
when your family your company and all
the people in your orbit have become the
targets of an unfounded politically
motivated Witch Hunt supported by
lawyers prosecutors and even the fake
news media
you really have no choice
we cannot permit a renegade and out of
control prosecutor to use this
investigation as a means of advancing
her political career
New York deserves better in this country
deserves better
this is a vindictive and self-serving
fishing Expedition the likes of which
this country has perhaps never seen
before
if there was any question in my mind
the rate in my home
two days ago Mar-A-Lago Palm Beach
Florida
by the FBI
just two days prior to this deposition
think of it wiped out any of that
uncertainty I have absolutely no choice
because the current Administration
and many prosecutors in this country
have lost all moral and ethical bounds
of decency
anyone in my position not taking the
Fifth Amendment would be a fool an
absolute fool
one statement or answer that is
ever so slightly off just ever so
slightly by accident by mistake
such as it was a
sunny beautiful day when actually it was
slightly overcast
would be met by law enforcement at a
level seldom scene in this country
because I've experienced it
the United States Constitution
exists for this very
purpose and I will utilize it to the
fullest extent and defend myself against
this malicious attack
by this Administration
this Attorney General's office and all
other attacks on my family
my business
and our country
accordingly under the advice of my
Council and for all of the above reasons
I respectfully declined to answer the
questions under the rights and
privileges afforded to every citizen
under the United States Constitution
this will be my answer to any further
questions
Mr Trump I take it you are are not going
to answer any questions about your
preparation today with your council is
that correct
and then
should I say this or should I respond to
that let's read that
for all of the reasons provided in my
answer which is Incorporated herein in
its entirety
I declined to answer the question
uh Mr Trump the focus of our
investigation and what we are primarily
going to cover today involves the
presentation of your statements of
financial condition between 2011 and the
present I take it you're generally
familiar with those statements is that
correct for all of the reasons provided
in my answer which is incorporated
herein
in its entirety I declined to answer the
question
one
oh mopey What a Sad Sack Donald Trump is
there X
of America remember when he stood on the
balcony and gasped for breath desperate
to look like a strong man what happened
to that guy
I'm sad you're asking me questions I'ma
plead the Fifth
there's several things there that I want
to talk about though that the
constitution
exists for this exact reason that if I
say it's sunny outside when it was
actually cloudy law enforcement's going
to show up the likes of which we've
never seen
it's to call it hyperbole isn't doing
Justice to hyperbole
that
um now I know he says I was just asking
that question why would someone uh take
the Fifth Amendment when they weren't
guilty if they were not guilty now I
know the answer to that question he
wasn't asking a rhetorical question he
was making a statement it was
declaratory oh if you do this it's like
the mob only guilty people take the
fifth he said
and then I want to remind you and the
audience dear listener dear viewer that
taking the Fifth Amendment it is a right
under the Constitution of the United
States against uh being forced to
self-incriminate it's not I don't want
to testify therefore I'm going to take
the Fifth Amendment it's not I'm tired
today therefore I'm pleading the Fifth
Amendment that's not what it exists for
it exists if you committed a crime you
cannot be compelled to testify against
yourself
so by him taking the fifth 400 times in
this case it means he believes
reasonably believes he could
self-incriminate by answering the
questions
retelling very telling
I know a lot of people out there this is
never going to go anywhere this is never
going to be any consequence I
am not so quick on that answer I think
that there's a very good chance that he
is going to face consequences maybe not
as quickly as we would like but I
believe it could happen
I'd love to have you connect with me
again I am at dollarmore on on the
social medias and I'm right here on
YouTube Jesse dollar more
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
welcome back to Ye Old David Pacman show
I am Jesse dollar Moore sitting in for
David while he is out vanquishing dumb
dumbs on their podcasts
what I want to talk about is the 2024
campaign for Republican for the nominee
for the Republican
um who's going to be the candidate
and it seems to have been really
supercharged this week with his Trump's
trips to to New Hampshire and South
Carolina but there's also been kind of a
tip for Tat with with Donald Trump and
the presumed main opponent that he'll
face Ron DeSantis and
we're going to give a little history
lesson here and then we're going to play
some Modern stuff but I want you we're
going to go current and then back in
time and then back to current
because just the other day on his on his
what they like to call Air Force One
even though it's just his personal plane
Donald Trump was asking questions
answering questions about Ron DeSantis
and Nikki Haley the former governor of
South Carolina his former U.N Ambassador
about their possible run for president
and he he labeled Ron DeSantis disloyal
and he said well I talked to her about
it I told her to follow her heart but
she said she'd never run against her
president Donald Trump
and they also got this jab in on Ron
DeSantis about his mishandling of kovid
and his when he closed all the beaches
really taking a shot at DeSantis and I
want to remind you of that and then
we'll go back in time a little bit watch
this
Nikki Haley called me the other day to
talk to me and talk to her for a little
while but I said look you know go buy
your heart if you want to run she's
publicly stated I would never run
against my president he was a great
president Florida was actually closed
for a great moment because I remember we
close to beaches and everything else you
know they're trying to rewrite history
it is ah it is fantastic listening to
Donald Trump whine about Ron DeSantis
trying to re-write history
these Republican politicians exist in a
in a in an alternate universe where
video cannot be summoned by the internet
and watched again here's Donald Trump
from just uh just a handful of years ago
during the coven crisis being asked by a
reporter about Ron DeSantis and his
performance during the pandemic the
height of the pandemic and he is just
checking off just a A plus a plus report
card for Ron DeSantis so the guy who
he's now criticizing for how he handled
covid just just months ago really was
had nothing but praise for the guy
as many schools and school districts are
closed
Florida Governor Rhonda San
out schools in May
um saying that many kids are not
vulnerable to this disease do you agree
with that assessment and do you believe
that schools would you recommend that
schools open up and to those states that
have well I have a lot of confidence in
Ron DeSantis a lot of faith in Ron
DeSantis to make the right decision he's
doing a great job as Governor Ron
DeSantis I I had read where he's
thinking about opening up the schools
earlier than the date the end of the
month uh I'd have to look at the numbers
it's got a lot of confidence in Ron
DeSantis check mark got a lot of faith
in Ron DeSantis
check mark
doing a doing a doing a great job Ron
DeSantis a plus brother
[Laughter]
Well Ron DeSantis obviously just the
other day was asked about this was asked
about the specific thing about Donald
Trump uh taking him to task and
criticizing him for kovid and Ron
DeSantis shot I'm actually a little
shocked about it his response because he
clapsed right back and he does it in a
real uh subtle underhanded dig at Donald
Trump about being a loser in his
election
watch this it really does open up the
the the possibilities for what the
Republican stage will look like uh
during the campaign check this out
criticized you a number of times in the
past couple of days uh on a number of
different issues
in the State uh I just saw that what I
would just say is this um I roll out of
bed I have people attacking me from all
angles it's been happening for many many
years and if you look at the good thing
about it though is like if you take a
crisis situation like covid you know the
good thing about it is when you're an
elected executive you have to make all
kinds of decisions you got to steer that
ship and the good thing is is that the
people are able to render a judgment on
that whether they reelect you or not and
I'm happy to say you know in my case not
only did we win re-election we won with
the highest percentage of the vote that
any Republican governor candidate has in
the history of the state of Florida
foreign
by the largest raw vote margin over 1.5
million votes than any governor
candidate has ever had in Florida
history and in fact we almost doubled
the previous record which I think was
like 780 000 vote margin and so what I
would just say is uh that verdict has
been rendered by the people of the State
of Florida
that's a dig that is absolutely a dig I
mean we'll paraphrase here it's look bro
I won my re-election what'd the other
guy do that's what he's doing here now
listen I'm I'm one who doesn't believe
Ron DeSantis had he's not ready for
Prime Time Ron DeSantis isn't ready to
meet Donald Trump on the stage I think
he will go the way of Lil Marco Rubio
and try his best to keep up with Donald
Trump but when the rubber hits the road
and when Ron DeSantis has to face the
many insults and the slings and the
arrows that will be delivered by Donald
Trump he's going to fold like a cheap
folding chair
[Laughter]
have what it takes he's not as slick
he's not as brutal he is not he's not
going to be able to withstand what
Donald Trump brings I think that's the
case for just about every one of these
Republicans you can't play the nice guy
after we've Fallen this far after the
cruelty has been amped up and ramped up
to the level that it has you're not able
to go back and be a John Kasich you're
not able to be a Mitt Romney you can't
even be a Chris Christie for that matter
and when a republican nomination for the
president of the United States so we'll
see what takes place but it is nice to
see that Ron descent isn't just going to
lay down
for Donald Trump that there is going to
be a fight because listen a fight among
them is good for us when when when these
fascists are are spending time wasting
time and energy battling one another
that is time not spent destroying the
country
let's stay with presidential politics
the 2024 race Donald Trump has been
receiving a little bit of criticism from
different circles about the fact that he
doesn't really have any policy
prescriptions for 2024. he rolled onto
the scene in 2015 rolled down his
escalator and came out and called
Mexicans rapists they're not sending
their best
I they're sending their worst the
rapists and the drugs and the and I
assume some of them are good people
you'll remember
and then it was Muslim bans and and all
of the rest
and now where do you go from there
it seems because Ron DeSantis again it
seems to be the chief opponent that we
will see
it seems that Donald Trump is going to
try to out DeSantis Ron DeSantis out
bigot Ron DeSantis out homophobe Ron
DeSantis he is going to try to
anti-trans bigot
off the charts and this is one of the
first policy prescriptions that Donald
Trump Allah his wall except now he wants
to oppress a marginalized population in
the United States here's Donald Trump
talking about what he wants to do with
education and trans rights
as part of our new credentialing body
for teachers we will promote positive
education about the nuclear family the
roles of mothers and fathers and
celebrating rather than erasing the
things that make men and women different
and unique I will ask Congress to pass a
bill establishing that the only genders
recognized by the United States
government are male and female and they
are assigned at Birth this is damaging
rhetoric it's obviously goofy coming out
of the mouth of this pumpkin head but
this is dangerous
the trans population in the United
States and likely the world uh possesses
some of the highest suicide rates
among any group
this is hateful this is damaging this is
harmful and for Donald Trump to tout
education about the nuclear family
what's next for Donald Trump well we're
gonna my new policy prescription is to
teach people to have sex with porn stars
and then pay them off with a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars cheat on all my
wives this is what you have to do to be
a good Christian man in America and
we're going to sign a bill to make it so
this is hypocrisy this is hate this is
xenophobia and really it boils down to
where does Donald Trump go from here
he's already he's played the greatest
hits we've seen the greatest hits in
2016. he tried to replace some of that
in 2020 he created new things to whine
and complain about and fear Monger about
in 2020. so where does he go from here
he's going to have to level up he's
going to have to ramp up the hatred and
the bigotry and the xenophobia
and the racism he's gonna have to do
that to to reconnect to the base to
inflame their passions this is what he's
going to have to do and listen I don't
know
I fear for the country I fear for
marginalized groups look I'm gonna be
okay
I'm a white guy in America
I could I could fail up and down the
street and still do okay
but it's it's marginalized groups it's
those desperate people coming from other
countries trying to make a better life
for themselves and Escape
brutality in their home countries that
are going to suffer it's the lgbtq
community in this country that will
suffer it is a rogue Maga Supreme Court
that has been appointed by Donald Trump
that's going to enact bring to fruition
this type of Oppression
we need to to brace ourselves for the
fight ahead we need to enlist those
around us who have compassion and
empathy for humankind to get to the
polls
your family your neighbors your friends
your co-workers your acquaintances these
conversations while uncomfortable need
to be talked about because you may know
a republican you may think to yourself
that he's a decent person
yeah he votes Republican but he doesn't
he doesn't care if if gay people get
married
but if that person this good and decent
person votes for someone who then
oppresses with their legislation who
then votes and enacts policy that does
oppress people
how is that good and decent person any
better than what they enacted through
their votes
and I think this is the way we need to
talk about this going forward into 2024
because we've witnessed
from a distance
fortunately for me but some not from a
distance millions of people live in
Florida they've witnessed Ron DeSantis
and the things he's been able to
accomplish with his Republican majority
they're trying to turn America in to
Florida and that is a terrifying
proposition
so I hope that you become as passionate
as I feel about this and move into 2024
to combat this nonsense because as scary
as it was in 2016 and as scary as it
could have been
after the 2020 election if it's gonna
get worse
I hope you're in for it
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show if you've
watched me for any amount of time at all
on my channel
I talk about race a lot I talk about the
bigotry and the hate that it exists
within the Republican Party
I talk about the Republican Party being
the largest and most organized white
supremacy organization on the globe
and one of the elements of that is
several members of Congress who are
vowed Christian nationalists and along
when you hear the term Christian
nationalists you should just
automatically understand that it is
white Christian nationalists
there was no black Christian nationalist
that's not a thing it is a an
exclusively white byproduct of racism
and fear
of their flavor of Christianity and
Marjorie Taylor green is one of these
people
a vowed Christian nationalist who speaks
at is invited to speak at and accepts
the invitation of Nick Fuentes to speak
at White Christian nationalist
conferences
and she now on committees
they're having a conversation in this
committee about the actions that led to
the death of Tyree Nichols in Memphis
Tennessee
and she talks
how terrible it was
and then inexplicably
expectedly but inexplicably pivots to
yeah that's really bad and all but
there's a lady in the audience whose
daughter was killed by police
that woman
her daughter's name was Ashley Babbitt
and then goes on to to have sympathy and
and draw attention to a woman who tried
to who was a q Anon adherent who tried
to overthrow the United States
government by force by overturning a
free and fair election who almost made
it onto the house floor to commit who
knows what Mayhem
watch this moment despicable moment for
Marjorie Taylor Green in committee
just the other day
oh and it was tragic and and extremely
difficult to watch I would also like to
point out that that city is Democrat
controlled and the five officers that
have been arrested and charged are black
and I think that this isn't isn't an
issue of uh racism or anything like that
I think I think that the judge and the
the jury in the trial needs to work out
what happened there but I share that
with you but I'd like to also point
something that I'd hope you share with
me there's a woman in this room whose
daughter was murdered on January 6
Ashley Babbitt
and Ashley Babbitt has there's never
been a trial as a matter of fact no one
has cared about the person that shot and
killed her and and no one in this
Congress has really addressed that issue
January 6 committee didn't address it
and I believe that there are many people
uh that came into the capitol on January
6 whose civil rights and Liberties are
being violated heavily and this
committee will I I hope uh Mr chairman
look into those civil rights abuses uh
because they're happening in a jail
right here in this city and I hope Miss
Norton uh will will care about that as
well
gross disgusting reprehensible
yeah Tyree that's sad and all yeah but
you know it's not racism because those
cops were black
you know the real Injustice is that
Ashley Babbitt was murdered she says she
categorizes a woman who stormed the
United States capital with a mob
amidst them were people with shirts that
said Camp Auschwitz on them
parading through the capitol with
Confederate flags
a hangman's Gallow constructed not
hastily constructed planned and executed
built on the lawn of the United States
capital but a thousand feet from where
they were chanting hang Mike Pence they
they came with an objective
to overturn a free and fair election to
disenfranchise you and millions of other
Americans if you voted for Joe Biden
because they wanted their dear leader
back in office a violent attempt at
overthrowing our government
she wasn't murdered
and those they are securing conviction
after conviction after conviction of
these individuals who did indeed attempt
to overthrow the United States
government
for the power for the for the party of
of of of Law and Order and back in the
blue and blue lives matter until
it butts up against their ideology and
their base
Tyree Nichols wasn't a domestic
terrorist
Tyree Nichols the the accusation from
the police that that ended up killing
him was that he recklessly drove
which has been rebutted by the chief of
police herself
in Mississippi or excuse me in Memphis
she says there's no evidence of that
so what we know is really there was no
crime committed
by Tyree Nichols there's no comparison
to be drawn between Ashley Babbitt the Q
Anon clown
and Tyree Nichols
but leave it to Marjorie Taylor green
leave it to the chaos caucus leave it to
the Republican party to put her on a
committee
to create a spectacle and a circus
and a distraction
from what really needs to be
accomplished in our country that is
where we are so thanks a lot Kevin
McCarthy
bang-up job you're doing a Speaker of
the House of Representatives making
cover for insurrectionists an
insurrection apologists
like Marjorie Taylor green
the other ask
s related to White Christian nationalism
in this country
is Tucker Carlson
who hosts a weekly racist fireside chat
on Fox News the highest rated program in
the history of the network hosted by
Tucker Carlson who has said that
immigrants didn't delineate between
illegal immigrants or legal immigrants
he just said immigrants make our country
poorer and dirtier he said it he has
said white supremacy is a myth it
doesn't exist he's now shifted they're
really the only racism is anti-white
racism
and he went on a this Jag last night
about the new crisis in America
they're gonna they're gonna gin this up
this new crisis is white racism
to his aging out audience filled with
lulling to sleep octogenarians
convincing an elder population that
there was a new crisis in America
watch this
so clearly Democratic party needs a new
emergency at least until we start
sending ground troops to Ukraine and the
population becomes suitably hysterical
again
so because they need an emergency they
found one and the new emergency turns
out to be the old emergency which is
white racism now unfortunately for the
Democratic party white racism is one
commodity
like cedar boards that's getting harder
to find very few unarmed black men are
killed by white cops these days where's
George Floyd when you need them so
instead in a pinch they've settled for
an unarmed black man killed by black
cops which they have informed us
nevertheless despite all appearances is
still the product of white racism and
Barack Obama enthusiastically agrees
this is Barack Obama's Lane
he was elected president twice on this
kind of stuff so he immediately jumped
into the middle of the Memphis tragedy
to remind us that white middle-class
Republicans did this blood is on their
hands Selma Dr King Rodney King Trayvon
Martin they're all the fruit of white
supremacy
how are they not the fruit of white
supremacy Tucker
how is it the disproportionate killing
of unarmed black men in this country is
not a byproduct of white supremacy and
systemic racism in our country
you vile putrid white supremacist
who still is propped up by advertisers
on Fox News
where's George Floyd when you need him
he declares
this is wretched reprehensible Behavior
a disgusting display
sponsored
by whomever
by the my pillow guy I guess and then
this crack about until we send ground
troops to Ukraine as though this is our
war
as though we've been invaded by Russia
or as though we've invaded Ukraine
it's all a play to create a frenzy and a
panic in his audience
as he declares the new crisis to be
white racism he's actually creating the
new crisis
on his program
listen I've talked a lot about Tucker
Carlson the googly-eyed feather duster
the haircut the soft skin smooth brain
and if it weren't for the fact that he
has the most ratings the greatest most
popular show in the history of Fox News
and Fox News Far and Away gets better
ratings than any other Cable News
Network if it weren't for that the fact
that people listen to him people trust
him people take his conspiracy theories
as fact
they take him at his word that he's
correct
you you can you can throw a suit or a
bow tie on a racist they're still a
racist just because he doesn't have a
skinhead
and Nazi tattoos doesn't make him a new
Nazi it's exactly what he is and he
thrives on it he profits off of it
and he has the ear of the only declared
candidate for president and the
Republican Party Donald Trump
he has regular text conversations with
Alex Jones
and he's now patterning his show
almost in I mean Sans selling vitamins
and supplements it's the same thing
this is dangerous
and we need to still be aware of it we
need to still keep on top of this and
keep it in the Forefront of our minds
and not just let it go away as well he's
just loopy in conspiracy theory he has
an audience
he rallies support people uh quote him
people cite him in their manifestos
after they commit violence
we need to stay on top of this
once again I am Jesse dollar Moore you
can find me online I am perpetually on
the internet uh you can subscribe to my
YouTube show dollar more daily just
search my name follow me on social media
I am on Twitter Instagram and Tick Tock
at dollar more and I'd love for you to
subscribe to my twice weekly podcast
called I doubt it wherever you find
podcasts
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
this story really hits home for me
um many of you know this past year I um
I was diagnosed with colon cancer
still very strange to say
just a few months ago I under underwent
surgery they removed about 35 percent of
my colon I'm healthy
a little fatter than I probably should
be but overall very healthy have great
blood pressure
all signs are great
so cancer snuck up on me
and it is tough nobody deserves it uh if
I wouldn't wish it on anybody it was a
very rough road to recovery
um I don't know how to categorize it
whether I almost lost my life or I could
have lost my life but it was it was
close
given if not for
um my my wife's concern
I might not be here given if not for her
convincing me
to go to the doctor I
it would have been curtains
for JD
so this story does hit home for me Jamie
Raskin
a beautiful man
congressman from a neighboring area
right here in Washington DC in Maryland
has been diagnosed with lymphoma
because I've just been introduced to to
cancer having it I don't know all the
different kinds I don't know exactly
which which which variety of lymphoma he
has
but he was in a committee
and he has now a bandana on his head
because he's undergoing chemotherapy and
there was an uncharacteristic and I
think wonderful
uh display by James Comer excuse me the
committee chairman
and they they're talking to him about
how they they're going to pray for him
and really show it was an outpouring of
support uncharacteristic in these
political times and I I just I wanted to
talk about it and play it for you
because not only is it beautiful and
something we should strive for to be
able to work together
um I think that if you are a Praying
person if you are a Karma person if you
are an energy person if you are a good
vibes person you should send them to
Congressman Jamie Raskin because he and
his family absolutely
are in need of it
watch this clip
that I yield to the distinguished
gentleman from Maryland ranking member
Jamie you're asking to introduce his
members but first I want to publicly say
Mr Askins we're all rooting for you we
know that you're gonna
win this battle if uh you're in our
thoughts and prayers and it's good to
see you here today I yield the ranking
member asking
Mr chairman thank you so much it means a
lot to me and I've been gratified to
receive so many kind words of uh
encouragement and sympathy from
colleagues on both sides of the aisle
and I hope that these expressions of
concern and solidarity will become seeds
of friendship over the year I certainly
plan on getting through this thing and
beating it and I thank you for your
patience and Indulgence
um
so listen
not only
is Jamie Raskin a a beautiful human
being not only is he a talented and uh
just a a fantastic lawyer and
constitutional scholar and expert but he
has a heart and a mind for the American
people he is a patriot for the country
and a patriot for its people
we need more like Jamie Raskin we need
more Democrats like Jamie Raskin and it
would be
an absolute tragedy
to lose Jamie Raskin as a representative
for Maryland
uh I mean there there's a number of
different directions we could talk about
now about Medicare Medicare for all
Universal Health care of whatever form
in this country but I can tell you from
first hand experience
that we need a system change a systemic
change
in the way that we deliver Health Care
in this country I'm sure he's getting
the best of the best care because that
he is a congressman and his the health
care plans up there are Cadillac they
are choice I work for the Senate even
and just as an employee uh it was
amazing I think it cost me twenty
dollars for my son to be born
but uh not everyone is as lucky
even the the the medical bills that my
wife and I are facing right now are
racking up because of the surgery and of
the treatment and everything else that
went in it and I think that we need to
be more Mindful and empathetic of others
who are going through something like
this who don't have the privilege
that Congressman Raskin has that I
indeed have
anyway
um thanks for indulging me a little
personal
um detour there I appreciate you very
much if you would like to subscribe to
my YouTube channel you can go over just
search my name you can find me on on the
internet on social media I am at dollar
more just about everywhere and of course
I host a twice weekly podcast with the
aforementioned Brittany page my wife and
content creator partner uh called I
doubt it twice weekly podcast and we'd
love to see you there
thanks a lot